[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about winning what a State
against eight again forget this a what I
felt when you were gonna free edit so I
didn't do it either I do do the neck did
you know yeah yeah that's what it is
people are waiting for that whatever we
want those hurry great ready I'll redo
it
hey guys welcome back to off the record
we talked about was actually play it up
I should put up I'll play it off to you
fell to lover I played it off but now
you said everything we're gonna say yeah
in different context see baby steps he's
learning so this dude um cuz it's
raining right now and people aren't used
to driving in the rain so I was delayed
by like 30 minutes because this dude
crashed into the you know those trash
cans that are filled with yeah so he
crashed into that and it went all over
the freeway kids in sand every way yeah
he was okay like they were helping him
out so he was alive like you and the car
wasn't too totaled it was like pretty
messed up in the front but not enough to
like smash him in the car oh my god
you're so nice geo the first reaction
was is he okay mine is you irresponsible
[ __ ] why are we need to make sure he's
okay so then I could call him an
irresponsible i QE r smart do it I'm
with job I'm usually you irresponsible
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] inconsiderate
[ __ ] if I see I'm dead I'm like good
whoa what if you hide your plane do you
never have don't have acclaimed yeah
that's me being inconsiderate they're
responsible yeah because I was in
considering if they're driving normal
you're not gonna be hydroplaning
oh I hide your plane if you're paying
attempt if you're really paying
attention right you'll see that big ass
puddle of water a mile
and you're supposed to be driving slower
slowing down way earlier you're supposed
to be doing all these things and if you
don't that's what happens you crash
I had Joe planed it was 3 a.m. and it
was 3:00 in the morning and I was
driving home from my boyfriend's house
because I wasn't allowed to spend the
night there in his back when I lived in
Santa Barbara and so it's pitch black
and I'm kind of tired I'm the only
person on the road but yeah there was a
big-ass puddle and like if roads that
aren't used to being rained on get
rained on all the oils come on the
freakin streets was she being
irresponsible then yeah she's already
driving was just tired you already know
you're not supposed to but I had to get
home and but I was safe I was only 65
but it it like yeah you're supposed to
go 55 no anyway sleep in the car Nicky
we're losing sleep in the car I went 180
and I was facing the traffic on the
freeway so luckily it was at 3 in the
morning no one else was on the freeway
but like one other person came up and
they're like oh [ __ ] headlights and they
like stop I was so shaken to because I
was like facing the wrong direction and
then it took a while for my car to start
up again but yeah so hydroplaning happy
once my mom I think any story that's
about to come out of your mouth no but
it was like this especially when it's
thriving [ __ ] David it was like this so
Sacramento rains an absorbent amount but
we were going through that long try a
little dry spell in the drought and then
we went it was just on an on-ramp and
then the car lost traction there's a
little some shitty luck how did that
happen to you I don't know but it was
very friend I would powered up at him
with zoom so you know what the sad thing
about hydroplaning up something is that
it's so [ __ ] slow that you just
screaming for a very long time so it was
I still make fun of my best friend till
this day about this because he denies it
but he literally scream like this he
went he still denies it you [ __ ] but
that's exactly and I cracked up because
it was just like this
[Applause]
it was so slow yeah didn't work as your
above it we hydroplane he just yes
well would you hydroplane it just slides
muster break you're supposed to put it
in neutral but like yeah you're not like
what's happening I'm like is this really
happening I was laughing the whole time
it was happening to me yeah if it was I
was an off-ramp and it curved and it was
at night I didn't even realize how much
it curved until I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm
going too fast and then it just started
did you hit a curb no I was turning it
enough to win it like it gained its
traction back it like lucky I didn't
gain any traction it just slid 3 miles
an hour right into that wall yeah a
second it's never been like that like
these stories are scary well if you're
out on the freeway right now or like
yesterday night it was so flooded like
if you were going even at 45 miles an
hour and you had a puddle you would hide
your plane for a quick second the brakes
at the right moment where's your street
yeah it was like a swimming pool yeah so
I'm like they gonna drink when we bought
the house - I was worried cuz the fires
were happening and that we were kind of
close to the fire so I was like oh no is
this in a fire zone and they're like no
but it is in a flood zone and I was like
I'll never rain sir yeah you have yeah
yeah yeah yeah your place is flooded
none on my place but like the roads are
like super flooded dude the [ __ ] is
straight up here with all those was like
[ __ ] whatever industrial buildings
like that left lane is [ __ ] like the
right lane cuz it's just yeah yeah I
have to avoid that entirely yeah I used
to love playing in death me too
any time I saw a gutter on my free
swimming pool yeah
my rain boots and I would just splash
did you guys speak rain boots you rich
as the paper boats like it would you
paper boats yeah like it I would go in
the gutter and hold my breath and I feel
like to see all the leaves cuz you would
watch all these like whitewater raft I'm
not gonna lie it sounds fun if you take
out the fact that it's [ __ ] the road
in [ __ ] la dude and you see like
whitewater rafting and all these fun
things you don't have access puts it is
mouth is all you got to do what you can
do that's true that's if when it's so
hard in Santa Barbara one time you know
how like when you get on the when you
get off the freeway like sometimes it
goes down and there's like it's like all
the roads go down into this dip and then
you have to go up to get back on the
freeway
so that part filled up like a swimming
pool all the way up to where the light
post oh we're like swinging on the light
poles to like going diving in there fun
except for that it's like toxic sewage
water when it's running water so it'll
filter itself out Oh big that's how it
works it's cooling yeah it's collecting
all of the sewers a lot of forces in
nature you don't know physics like the
Sun is probably gonna yeah kill it later
yeah you don't know that's what tank is
gonna be doing sewage ditch just [ __ ]
enjoying do you remember when it was
flooding like crazy in Texas and all
over and people were just jet skiing on
their front what did you see that sounds
all file is great for jet skiing to like
save animals to like they were like jet
skiing around neighborhoods like trying
to find a tree yeah it was pretty sad
there's so nice I don't think I would
think about that [ __ ] I'm just like
there I'm how awarding people were just
paddle board from house to house that's
crazy I want you guys like on someone's
door we made a pie oh yeah we made a pie
yesterday I should have saved some
coffee mo meringue Lima real
ringing hi Mariah it's our baby give me
a scoop of weight so there's no creme or
eggs no Tuesday make some [ __ ] yeah it's
important you should call out I don't
think I heard anybody say let me get a
scoop of pie before I think said that
without even thinking about utensils be
hearing his hand going into it you
[ __ ] animal picture my finger no
making a nice cut in the crust I knew it
go in you're gonna scrape with your
dirty ass fingers and then cut the crust
with your head you son of a [ __ ] my
hands are clean
just clean it let the orange peel make
sure you get a little of everything cuz
we made the crust by hand with our hands
and our a lot of good I really don't
like lemon meringue cuz it's really hard
to make this now oh yeah not with magic
no Baba I'll tell you the secret
ingredient after you taste it your be
yeah I'm not vegan
oh I eat mostly plant-based and I try to
avoid dairy works the fluff then you'll
find out it this is this is this is
straight-up like [ __ ] egg white or
some [ __ ] what is this that's vegan
though that should look like shaving
cream
no tricky thing you have to try it
together it's a whole it's a whole
concept experience hey Nikki you dare me
to eat the whole thing
no no for the [ __ ] that we want to do
the whole thing you bastard very
complimented we're flattered
did you take all the money I do all it
[Laughter]
would you think of it yet David I hate
lemon meringue tastes like it though
it's really good I mean it does but not
like the [ __ ] and extra concentrated
yeah like the blah I hate I don't like
American natural lemon and those lemons
are very good a vegan version of it yeah
and also I mean it's not fresh because
we made it last night but that's good I
like that
you okay you want to know the secret
ingredient yeah what is it last night
but now it's kidney stones yeah lemon
heads you melted lemon only biggest once
it's bean water with bean water for
Bonzo bean water yeah damn bean water so
do you get a can of like garbanzo beans
and then get the lid and you whip and
whip it up and it's just like a very
acceptable version of a vegan pie that I
enjoy thanks David it was good cuz like
most most like vegan desserts I really
hate but I got plans
thanks yeah I'm proud of it you actually
have fun baking yeah except I
accidentally picked a recipe that took
like seven and I didn't know I thought
it was just like oh we just bake a pie
luckily we had already planned me
staying there because I wanted to wait
out the traffic's and she is so far away
don't like this worked out yeah you
spent the entire day together you guys
gonna move closer away I know you got a
house it's the starter home mm-hmm their
credit is barely getting better from
like pull the sock everybody in Vegas
that would be so fun in Vegas uh-huh
it's really cheap and there's no tags
there's no capital gains tax we want the
cul-de-sac but I don't want the Vegas
weather yeah I mean I'm in the same boat
but Steve keeps convincing me every day
for Vegas he just wants to gamble our
friends just moved there and they
[ __ ] love it because they say it
operates kind of like a small town we're
like everyone knows your name they go to
the beans go
but you know what you know what our
financial advisor told us he has clients
that moved a client that moved over
there cause he's bald as [ __ ] and in the
minute the kid needed to start school
they were like oh [ __ ] the school sucked
all the way back to Orange County just
back yes because of the school is just
way better remember become dealers over
there okay fine I called the SAC here
then do you want your kid to grow up to
be a showgirl no to be part of blue man
there's nothing wrong with that Joe why
you put it down on the show girls watch
I'm not I'm just saying is that soda you
want all them that did sound like a
question um all right no I would I like
I've never lived outside of California
before so that would be scary but I like
a good a mansion em I don't destroy my
biggest dream yeah like if we live in
Vegas that's gonna destroy the magic of
Vegas hmm maybe but I can't I guess
there won't be paradise whoa that's like
saying living here ruins the magic of
Disneyland where do we hardly ever go to
Disneyland but like if you live on the
outskirt of Vegas you're hardly a big
girl i'ma be living in a hotel
what about this I mean not Disney [ __ ]
me up
what about Hawaii can you guys live in a
life I can to live in Hawaii neither my
brother yeah it's two single single
culture aha yeah it's just I could stay
there you guys just stay home anyway
mm-hmm but this so I agree with that and
that's Bart's argument all the time but
for me I'm glad I talked about it
options huh give me the office exactly
give me give me options cuz once I feel
like I have no options and I'm forced to
just you know I'm like I can't breathe
oh my god no but what did what did you
what do you do what my cousin does where
50% of his time is spent on the mainland
in a desert that's expensive yeah it is
expensive and then you have to catch a
flight every time you make money hours
no no no okay so we'll get a cold a sack
here yeah where we could
we afford Riverside maybe not the
helling ourselves you can't even before
Riverside it's gonna be like Modesto or
Rancho Cucamonga I don't think we could
afford that dude really
it's that Papa now I mean to build a
whole entire cul-de-sac we're talking
about Apple Valley we're gonna go we're
gonna go [ __ ] find the worst cheapest
like metric Athena yeah but like the
cheapest version of that area like
[ __ ] I don't know like yeah like palm
not Palmdale or something I guess we
gotta just buy a prebuilt called a
second where was that
the place where we filmed gun come from
one gun through white horse ranch that
shit's full of hole stabs girl that's
[ __ ] that doesn't even have any city
hookups area is just that's like we
can't afford it there's no plumbing I
rather be in Hawaii than there cuz
there's nothing there
yeah where it's like okay do you know
where morongo casino is oh yeah so
imagine going past the mountains into
the desert where there's no civilization
there's a bunch of like different
homesteads that are kind of off the grid
there's like one gas station yeah that
seems kind of fun though you guys know
if I could do that man I'm like it's
weird because I never thought that I
could live in LA for a long extended
period of time
did you have an experience the real
alley well I've experienced a really
that's not what I like I like South
Pasadena area I want to say I just I've
just got a millionaire I want to live
closer to the beach but it's so
expensive to cook what about Central
Coast the Central Coast like we're where
you grew up
they're like the small towns like that's
all over the PCU yeah I would have mind
that and there's really good schools
yeah there's no Asian food what are you
talking about it's California yeah it's
different that's all song specially
sushi in Santa Barbara
oh my if the place has samurai rolls
that's my Asian food I don't know what
that is
Samurai Shodown roll they catch the fish
right there on the pier and they put it
in a sushi it's so [ __ ] good
yeah but fresh sushi isn't good though I
mean like there's Asian food but if they
serve Thai food with sushi that's not
really no fusion that's what I'm talking
about like this it's hard to get like
really dope Asian so you're saying that
no Asians live in Santa Barbara know
what I'm saying what I'm saying is like
they can't compete with LA or San
Francisco yes what I'm talking about
like if I want tacos I find some random
truck in the middle that East LA that's
what I call it Santa Barbara has so many
tacos fire I believe but actual Asian
food that's gonna compete with someone
that's smoking a cigarette while he's
cooking okay so you're always on a diet
how many times are you consuming said
Asian options I will say like it's hard
to order a delivery after a certain hour
in Santa Barbara that's really
frustrating this everyone though that's
not just Senator Barbara they say we're
besides LA in New York and San Francisco
luxury in LA of like oh it's ten o'clock
let's order whatever we want the only
way we're all gonna be able to have a
cul-de-sac in LA is having a [ __ ] ton of
money because we're gonna have to go
into an area and start buying out the
homes yeah see you all right so we got
to do what in those gated community the
newer ones and like what what what bark
learn geo by that right so we got to
find something brand new yeah I've been
get in no one's building everyone gotta
start saving
we just gotta start saving Oh plots of
land are just for Blasio and I heard
that it's like it's like less expensive
to build your own house from scratch oh
we're a lot of land yeah in Palmdale in
the Mojave Desert
I would agree true you can't get a bank
loan for the plot of land only for the
house on top of it
so it's the way you have the strategy to
finance it from what I've been told is
if you want to do this from scratch
method you have to buy the lot plot of
land that's what you are
that's what you can get a bank loan
floor for but then that construction
because now that's a separate project
you got to pay that cash so is the other
way around so now if you buy a plot of
land where I just saw and pop up in
South Pass empty land is already a
million then you spend like let's say
five hundred thousand on the house you
got to come up with that five hundred
thousand dollars cash on your own and
then later on if you want to play the
game what's the houses built what they
say is like because you've built the
house there's equity built now there's
actual like house there then you can
refinance that whole thing like against
yourself or whatever you know what the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] means
and then you calm down calm down then
you can breathe so well I don't remember
but like I've seen documentaries
overhead like Sears used to sell homes
and you just bought you just want like a
build a home okay well I heard about
that anyone used to do that's why a lot
of the cookie cutter homes like from the
1960s they all like look the same
because you buy them from Sears and they
just have like different options you can
pick one two or three and then you pick
that one and then they just they send a
box over and they made you build a house
yeah the only way we're gonna be able to
achieve what we want as soon as we want
is building a cul-de-sac in Tennessee
don't swing that thing around I feel
like you're sip it's gonna like hit me
it's Drive but can we go somewhere with
the beach I like the beach I love how
come we don't like to be I like the
beach it's just a little gloomy there
school it's really windy for once
I'm watching West whether she has a
[ __ ] blanket on right now I'm wearing
a punch what you invest in Patagonia
it's gloomy and when like just the
spring right like the beach is always
yeah and it's called it's the marine
layer it burns off by the middle of the
day it's not ever being sunny all the
time oh yeah close to the beach not you
know in a beach city but I live in Santa
Barbara and it's like yeah for the
mornings it is foggy and then it burns
off at like noon oh is that what that is
yeah but I will say at night if it's
like a little chilly because there's a
lot of moisture in the air it seeps
through like your jacket like you can't
just wear like you
heavys t-shirt things getting under your
skin mustard [ __ ] - mm-hmm [ __ ] Russ
hell effect like in Hawaii houses my
braces rusted to our [ __ ] Brown he's
just smiling all the time you just don't
close your mouth ever we should just get
like property all over and then have our
own timeshares oh that's a good idea
[Music]